this is a bit I did it was a bit online
okay where they were like we want you to
create some social cuts for the Super
Bowl commercial and I was supposed to be
in the extended version on Youtube hold
on so you were in T-Mobile Super Bowl
commercial now I was supposed to be
I did this cut for socials where I acted
like I was the director my fans love you
guys but it was a joke they were like so
proud of my girl knew she could do it
like she directed this watching the
T-Mobile commercial because my bestie
director
we are currently on set for my T-Mobile
Super Bowl commercial I am the director
the star the writer the filmographer
filmographer I actually invented that
time
it's not with these guys you know
zero idea
[Music]
moving on guys moving on we got it
moving on